you
where have you been oh my god Jesus what
are you doing what have you been on D we
are so worried we just went to a movie
will you admit that some to mobile who
went with you no one it was just us -
what James he was in there you are
grounded one month fifty what this is
ridiculous
auntie June is a friend of mine Mahajan
t but each minute eat sorrowful
definitely meet cam drinking with drugs
so God knows what is that all you think
that people do here yes well here's a
shocker mom we live in America for
Americans it's not happening as long as
you live in this house you live in
Palestine you're delusional super if Li
the mixture between religion and
identity religion and nationality how
like in people's mind sometimes that
they get that gets so mixed up that for
them if you're an Arab you're a Muslim
if you're an Arab you're just like one
sided they just like can't see the
aspect of of your humanity I think it's
a movie about like human beings in a
journey I mean I like I like really
these kind of scripts because they have
like they have a real touch to the human
side of people living their life but at
the same time in in a in a in a context
right and though the context of the
movie is the immigration unlike how
people deal with it but it's still
really about their human journey in
within like a period of time of their
life I think there's a lot of sharing in
this movie and it's I don't think it's
about messages I it's more about like
really a sharing of a human journey of
characters that are really very
well-written and there they are thrown
out there in the air in a movie to make
you just like think whatever you think
when you walk out
that movie